And the sons of Noah that went forth of
the Ark were Shem and ham and Japheth.
And Ham is the father of Canaan.
These are the three sons of Noah
and of them was the whole earth.
Overspread and Noah began
to be a HUD husbands men.
And he planted a vineyard and he
drank of the wine and was drunk.
And,
and he was uncovered
within his tent and Ham.
The father of Canaan saw the nakedness
of his father and told his two brethren
without,
and Shem,
and Japheth took a garment and laid upon
both their shoulders and went backward
and covered the nakedness of their father.
And their faces were backward,
and they saw not their father's nakedness.
And Noah awoke from his wine and knew
what his younger son had done unto him.
And he said,
curse had to be Canaan,
a servant of servants shall
he be unto his brethren.
And he said,
blessed shall be the Lord God of Shaman.
Canaan shall be his servant,
and God shall enlarge Japheth.
And he shall dwell in the tents of Shem.
And Canaan shall be his servant.
And Noah lived after the flood,
350 years and all the days of
Noah were 950 years and he died
and the whole earth was of one
language and of one speech.
Okay.
So
I remember thinking about this story,
it's gotta be 30 years ago
and I think the meaning of
the story stood out for me.
Sometimes when you read
complicated materials,
sometimes a piece of it will stand out.
It's for some reason
it's like it glitters.
I suppose that might be one
way of thinking about it.
It's it,
you're in sync with it and you
can understand what it means.
I've really experienced that
reading the Tao Te Ching,
which is document I would really like
to do a lecture on at some point because
some of the verses I don't understand,
but others stand right out
and I can understand them.
And I think I understood what this
part of the story of Noah meant.
And I think it means,
you know,
we talked a little bit about
what nakedness meant in
the story of Adam and eve.
And the idea essentially was that to
know yourself naked is to become aware of
your vulnerability,
the physical,
your physical boundaries
in time and space and your,
your,
your physiological,
your fundamental physiological
insufficiencies as they
meet might be judged by
others.
So there's biological insufficiency that
sort of built into you because you're a
fragile mortal,
vulnerable half insane creature.
And that's,
that's just an existential truth.
And then of course,
even merely as a human being,
even with all those faults,
there are faults that you have that are
particular to you that might be judged
harshly by the group while might be,
we'll definitely be judged
harshly by the group.
And so to become aware of your nakedness
is to become self conscious and to,
and to,
to know your limits and
to know vulnerability.
And that's what is revealed to him
when he comes across as farther naked.
It's so the question is what does
it mean to see your father naked?
And it seems to me,
and especially in an
inappropriate manner like this,
it,
it's,
it's as if ham,
he does the same thing that happens
in the Mesopotamian creation myth.
When when tie him out an absolute
give rise to the first God's there,
they're the father of the
eventual day of redemption.
Marduk they're very careless and noisy
and the kill appsu their father and
attempt to inhabit his corpse.
And that makes timeout enraged.
And so she bursts forth
from the darkness to,
to do the men.
It's like a precursor to the flood
story or an analog to the flood story.
And I see the same thing happening
here with him is that he's,
he's insufficiently
respectful of his father.
And the question is exactly
what does the farther represent.
And you could say,
well,
there's,
there's the father that you
have and that's a human being.
That's,
that's a man like other men,
a man among men.
But then there's the farther as such.
And that's the spirit of the father.
And insofar as you have a father,
you have both at the same time.
You have the personal father that's a
man among other men just like anyone else
who's father.
But insofar as that man is your father,
that means that he's something
different than just another person.
And what he is is the incarnation
of the spirit of the father.
And to see that,
to take it to what,
to disrespect that carelessly,
maybe even he like,
no,
it makes a mistake,
right?
He
produces wine and gets himself drunk.
And you might say,
well,
you know,
if he's sprawled out
there for everyone to see,
it's hardly hams fault if
he stumbles across him.
But the book is laying out a
danger and the danger is that,
well maybe you catch your father at his
most vulnerable moment and if you're
disrespectful then you transgress
against the spirit of the father.
And if you transgress against the spirit
of farther and Louis Spirit of the
father and lose respect for
the spirit of the father,
then that is likely to
transform you into a slave.
That's a very interesting idea and I
think it's particularly interesting.
Maybe not particularly interesting,
but it's,
it's particularly Germane,
I think,
to our current cultural situation because
I think that we're pushed constantly
to see the nakedness of our father,
so to speak,
because of the intense criticism that's
directed towards our culture and the
patriarchal culture,
so to speak.
We're constantly exposing its weaknesses
and vulnerabilities and let's say
nakedness,
and
there's wrong with criticism,
but the thing about criticism is the
purpose of criticism is to separate the
wheat from the chaff.
It's not the burn
everything to the ground,
right?
It's to say,
well,
we're going to carefully look at this.
We're going to carefully differentiate.
We're going to keep what's good and
we're going to move away from what's bad,
but the point of the criticism
isn't to identify everything is bad.
It's two separate.
What's good from what's bad so that you
can retain what's good and move towards
it,
and to be careless at that is is deadly
because you're inhabited by the spirit
of the father,
right?
In so far as you're a
cultural construction,
which of course is something that the,
that the postmodern,
Neo Marxists are absolutely
enthusiastic about.
You're a cultural construction in so
far as you're a cultural construction,
then your inhabited by
the spirit of the father.
And to be disrespectful towards that
means to undermine the very structure that
makes you not all of what you are.
Certainly certainly not
all of what you are,
but a good portion of what you are in,
in so far as you're a
socialized cultural entity.
And if you pull out the,
if you pull the foundation
out from underneath that,
what do you have left it,
you can hardly manage on your own.
You know,
it's just not possible.
You're a cultural creation.
And so Hamm makes this desperate error
and is careless about exposing himself to
the vulnerability of his
father or something like that.
He does it without sufficient respect.
And the judgment is that
not only will he be asleep,
but so all of his descendants and he's
contracted with the other two sons who
I suppose are willing to give their
father the benefit of the doubt,
something like that.
And so when they see him
in a compromising position,
they handle it with respect and,
and,
and don't capitalize on it.
And,
and maybe that makes them strong.
That's what it seems to me.
And so I think that's
what that story means.
It has something to do with respect.
You know?
And the funny thing about
having respect for your culture,
and I suppose that's partly why
I'm doing the biblical stories,
is because they're part of,
they're part of my culture.
They're part of our culture perhaps.
But there they're certainly part of
my culture and it seems to me that
it's worthwhile to treat that with
respect to see what you can glean from it
and,
and not kick it when it's down,
let's say.
So.
And so that's how the story of no ends,
you know?
And the thing too is Noah is actually a
pretty decent incarnation of the spirit
of the father.
That,
which I suppose is one of the things
that makes Hams misstep more egregious is
that,
I mean,
Noah just built an ark and got
everybody through the flood.
Man,
you know,
it's not so bad in.
So maybe the fact that he happened to
drink too much wine one day wasn't enough
to justify humiliating him.
And you know,
I don't think it's pushing the limits
of symbolic interpretation to note on a
daily basis that were
all contained in an arc.
Right?
And that's the arc that you could
think about that as the arc that's been
bequeathed to us by our forefathers.
That's the tremendous
infrastructure that we inhabit,
that we take for granted because it works
so well that protects us from things
that we can't even imagine.
And we don't have to imagine
because we're so well protected.
And so one of the things
that's really struck me hard,
I would say about the disintegration and
corruption of the universities is the
absolute in gratitude
that goes along with that.
Criticism,
as I said,
is for fine thing,
if it's done in the
spirit in a proper spirit,
and that's the spirit of separating
the wheat from the chaff.
But it needs to be
accompanied by gratitude.
And it does seem to me that
anyone who lives in the west,
in the western culture at this time,
in history and in this place and who
isn't simultaneously grateful for that is,
is,
is half blind at least because
it's never been better than this.
And it could be so much worse and it's
highly likely that it will be so much
worse because for most of human history,
so much worse is the norm.